Speaker 1: An antisemitic attacker yelled
Kanye 2024 while committing the attack.
And we are going to talk about what happened. And
importantly, this is not about Kanye being legally
responsible for the attack or anything like it.
This is about realizing that when high profile
celebrities like Kanye West make anti-Semitic
comments, it contributes to normalizing and
accepting anti-Semitism in society. That's the
point that we are making here. Let's go to The
Washington Post article. Attacker yells
Kanye 2024 during anti-Semitic Assault,
Police Say. NYPD is investigating an alleged
attack in Central Park this week in which a man
in his mid-forties assaulted a 63 year old man
and spewed anti-Semitic comments before yelling
out Kanye 2020 for, of course, a reference to
Kanye's anti-Semitic rhetoric. The older man was
walking in Central Park about 7:30 p.m. Wednesday
when the other man allegedly hit him from behind.
According to police, when the older man fell to
the ground, he broke his hand and chipped a tooth.
The attacker then uttered numerous anti-Semitic
comments towards the man, according to police,
before the attacker fled on a bicycle with a
trailer featuring a sign reading Hungry, Disabled.
Police say he referenced the artist formerly known
as Kanye West, who has issued several anti-Semitic
tirades, saying Kanye 2020 for a 63 year old man
has not been publicly identified. Anti-Semitic
attacks in the U.S. are at an all time high. So
when high profile individuals make statements or
they engage in behaviors that are perceived
as anti-Semitic or that are anti-Semitic,
it can give the impression that this type of
bigotry is acceptable and mainstream. And in fact,
when it comes specifically to anti-Semitism, it's
very popular. It's very in vogue to say we don't
even really need to treat it as seriously as other
isms because Jews are privileged in 2022. We've
talked about that extensively and we've talked
about how that very refrain is in and of itself
based on anti-Semitic tropes and stereotypes.
But this is why it's not as simple as many of the
emails I get from some of you lovely people who
say, it doesn't matter that Kanye's anti-Semitic,
fine, maybe he's anti-Semitic. Some people email
me and they say the stuff is Kanye. Kanye saying
is true. Okay. There's people who recognize, yes,
these are anti-Semitic tropes, but it doesn't
matter just Kanye. It doesn't matter. It's a
vicious circle, in fact. And it matters very
much. The use of anti-Semitic language or imagery
by celebrities fuels the spread of that very
misinformation and those conspiracy theories and
and tropes, which then in the followers of these
celebrities, creates a new cycle of emboldening
and furthering and exacerbating those very
beliefs, which only creates more of it. It's
a vicious circle, and we've seen many examples
of this. It's not only Kanye. I mean, listen, we
can go back to Henry Ford if you really want to,
but without going back that far, Mel Gibson, in
2006, Mel Gibson had this incident where he was
arrested, drunk driving, and he made a bunch of
anti-Semitic statements to the officer. He said to
the guy, Are you a Jew? Crazy. But I believe the
officer was Jewish, which is just I mean, that's
another whole incredible coincidence of saying
the Jews are responsible for the wars in the world
and all this stuff. And, you know, he eventually
apologized. And I think Mel Gibson's acting again,
I don't know. But at the time, it created a lot
of this Mel Gibson's willing to say stuff a lot of
people in Hollywood aren't willing to say. Louis
Farrakhan we've talked about many times before,
he's the leader of the Nation of Islam. Very
long history of anti-Semitic statements.
Blame the Jews for 911. Typical stuff. Jews are
actually the ones in control of the government,
that type of thing. He has a significant following
and there are lots of folks in the Nation of Islam
who maybe don't come in with particular views
about Jews, but there they end up informed by
Louis Farrakhan. And then you have a whole new
generation of people who repeat the same stuff.
An Ice Cube had an incident. Rapper Ice Cube
promoted some conspiracy theories about Jews on
social media, claimed Jews are responsible for the
slave trade, which isn't true. And he responded
by saying, I'm not promoting anti-Semitism. I'm
raising questions about the history of slavery,
questions that are very extensively answered by
by history. So it's a vicious circle of stuff.
The vicious circle itself perpetuates
the belief, and then it creates more of a
problem. And anti-Semitism, like other forms of
bigotry, is often based on negative stereotypes
and prejudices about Jews. The prejudices
themselves make it easier for people to believe.
The conspiracy theories. And even if there's no
evidence to support them, it's a feedback loop.
It's like if you put a microphone up to a speaker
and then, you know, a feedback loop. There are
also psychological factors because research has
found that people are more likely to believe
conspiracy theories when they're feeling anxious
or uncertain in a time of crisis or change. They
become more susceptible to believing this stuff.
And we have a right wing party in the United
States, the Republican Party, that for a decade
now has been based on using fear and making people
afraid that they're going to lose their way of
life or their lives or whatever. And that actually
primes people to be even more likely to fall for
this stuff in the first place. So the full circle
of the Kanye anti-Semitism and we'll follow up on
the story probably on a forthcoming bonus show.